okay
um does the microphone work
hi everyone my name is Mega and today
I'll be talking about how we can use AI
assistance to help teach humans motor
control tasks like parking a car or
riding in a more reliable and consistent
way
so humans need to perform a variety of
motor control tasks in our everyday
lives such as to our occupations like
surgery for fun and enjoyment like
playing a sport and in everyday tasks
like writing
however money motor control tasks are
challenging to learn
and often take years of practice for
especially for those who are unable to
get access to good specialized teaching
furthermore motor control tasks are even
more challenging to teach others
for example there may be many people
around us like our parents or friends
who are able to perform a motor control
task well they may be experts at the
task but they lack the ability to teach
the task to others because teaching is a
much harder task teaching requires
having good communication ability and
lesson design information it requires
understanding the task Beyond rote
memory and it requires an awareness of a
particular student's capabilities
um and furthermore this problem will
only become worse as we introduce uh
more new motor control tasks especially
in the realm of human AI coordination
for example with self-driving cars we're
introducing a new kind of control task
where humans need to learn when to
intervene or need to detect when the car
is entering an unsafe situation and be
able to quickly take over so you can
view that as a new kind of control task
or an assistive robot tally operation in
applications such as assistive surgery
humans now need to learn how to operate
these really novel control interfaces
and how to augment the robot's
capabilities in the most Safe Way
so what makes teaching motor control
tasks in particular so challenging
first they often require having access
to specialized instructors who have a
deep knowledge of the different skills
required for the motor control task
second there are strong individual
variations in the students trying to
learn them such as in sports a human's
height or arm span or whether they're
left-handed or right-handed a teacher
needs to be able to handle all these
individual variations
and then finally there are also diverse
physical conditions in the task such as
a patient's body during surgery that a
teacher needs to help teach humans to be
able to be robust to when they're
actually performing the task
so in our work we ask whether AI
assistants can help teach humans motor
control tasks and in particular we ask
whether we can leverage all this expert
human knowledge out there of how to
perform a motor control task all these
experts who are able to perform the task
can we use AI assistance to help
transfer that Knowledge from experts to
other humans who are novice students who
want to learn how to perform the task
themselves
so AI assistance has helped bring more
accessible and uniform teaching in
simpler domains like foreign language
learning and Duolingo is a pretty
popular example of this
so let's uh dig deeper into how Duolingo
uses AI assistance
first we have this notion of skill
identification or identifying what parts
of a task fall under certain way and
filled Concepts like grammatical
Concepts or subject Concepts
we also have this notion of
individualization automatically
identifying the weakest Concepts such as
the weakest words a student is
struggling with and there's been a lot
of recent work including my work in ACL
last year that's focused on improving
this individualization process using you
know techniques such as modern language
models and the knowledge of language
within them
and then finally there's this notion of
curricula creation which we'll call
jills so what is the right kind of
practice method a mechanism that
students should go through in order to
improve on the skills they're struggling
with and there's been a lot of work in
the reinforcement learning community on
optimal curriculum design and activity
sequencing
so this process is a lot easier in
common education domains like foreign
language learning and Mathematics and
that's because the skills in these
domains have been standardized by
Educators over years and they're also
easy to detect because they're often
text based
and the key challenge for us with motor
control tasks is that we're dealing with
a new kind of data we're dealing with
trajectories over time which is a lot
more complex
so let's look at a specific motor
control task writing in this example a
user is writing Balinese characters
there may be many experts who are able
to do this but uh they might not be
familiar with how to teach this task
and we can clearly see that this is a
trajectory over time which we can
formulate as a markup decision process
with an initial State that's the x y
coordinate the action sequence of X Y
movements by the user and a reward
function that corresponds to their
target goal sequence so the full
sequence of characters they want it
right
and then we have this notion of a
scenario which is that in the initial
State and reward pair
and then we can say that a trajectory is
a sequence of State action tuples that
correspond to a particular scenario so a
particular kind of Target sequence the
user wants to write
and so now let's be more formal about
our three teaching components in the
context of trajectories over time for
motor control tasks starting with skill
identification
how do we identify motor control skills
from motion trajectories
so the key idea with our work is that we
borrow from the reinforcement literature
a set of algorithms on unsupervised
skill Discovery and while our method is
agnostic to the particular algorithm
I'll focus on one in particular called
compile
so loosely speaking compile is an
autoencoder decoder framework that
learns to break down expert trajectories
into smaller segments of State action
sequences that can correspond to
different skills
and in particular there are two
components a boundary Network that
learns to predict the boundaries of the
next skill segment and an encoding
Network that learns to predict the
latent skill code corresponding to that
segment
and then we have a decoding Network that
tries to recover the action sequence
based on the latent code and the
objective we're trying to optimize for
is the Reconstruction loss
so then when we want to train a compile
model we can consider having a data set
of expert demonstrations corresponding
to different uh scenarios
put that into the network and then
you'll get a trained compile model
and then at test time we can provide a
novel sequence a novel State a
trajectory of State action tables
put that in as input to a compile model
and then what you can see here is that
compile has broken it down into skill
boundaries so the different where each
skill starts and ends and these codes
that I will identify the different
skills and you can see here in this
fighting task that this horn shape that
appears in many different Balinese
characters are all being identified as
skill 3.
so here the key idea is that we're using
a combination of expert demonstrations
and unsupervised skill Discovery to help
break down this complex data type of
trajectories over time
so now how do we handle
individualization and identify
individual expertise from student motion
trajectories
so we showed how compile can take as
input and expert demonstration
but what happens when we have a novice
student demonstration that's a lot
noisier than an expert and doesn't kind
of have all the skills
when we input it and to compile we can
see that compile may not be able to
detect all the skills for the checking
now because the student hasn't been able
to perform them and so in this example
compile is able to detect skill one and
the boundaries for that but then because
the student is starting to struggle at
the part of the sequence where skill 2
is needed compile is not able to detect
skill 2 and then subsequently scale 3
and skill 4. so we can now use this to
help determine which skills we want to
penalize and help the student learn
later on
but there's this other idea of the
sequential ordering of the skills where
because the student was starting to
struggle with skill two they never
really even got to attend Skill 3 and
skilled four so maybe we want to
penalize skill 2 more than Skill 3 and
skill 4 because we don't really have
enough information on whether the
student is able to you know actually
perform skill for
so we can have this temporal Decay term
J to handle this
and so then if this particular student
attempt has a given reward and for the
writing task reward can be the pixel
wise distance between the student and
expert trajectory and also a combination
with the uh furthest along the x-axis
the student is able to write given this
reward function we can now distribute
the reward across the different skills
as penalties and weighted accordingly by
the temporal Decay term
that the student got a pretty high
negative reward of negative 12 then we
could assign a lot of penalty to skill
too and then less so to skill three and
skill four
and then we have a diverse set of
scenarios that require a diverse set of
skills according to the expert we can
then use this to get a pretty reliable
estimate of what are the skills the
student is indeed struggling with and we
can formulate this creation of a diverse
set of scenarios as a maximum set
coverage problem over the expert
demonstrations and skills
and so again the key idea here is
individualization where we're using this
to now kind of identify for different
students what are the different skills
that they're each struggling with so
some skills might be uniformly
challenging but others are based on
individual student capabilities they may
be struggling with more so than others
and then finally curricular creation how
do we create novel joules that now
Target these individualized skills that
we want to help students practice
so in many motor control tasks such as
basketball we have this idea of drills
which are repetitive sequences like
dribbling or repeated shooting with the
ball that Target particular skills but
also in common context that they appear
so shooting from particular locations or
dribbling in a way that one might
dribble in an actual game
and so for our tasks say we see that a
student is struggling with skill one
what kind of gel should that student uh
practice with
so we can introduce a hyper parameter
controlling the degree of repetition
and then also a parameter controlling
the common context so the context length
so given a set of expert demonstrations
what are the common context skill one
appears in and if it's a context of two
then what are the what is the second
most common skill that appears with
skill one most often so that the student
can help practice the transitions
between skill one and the context it
often appears in
so then what we can see here is this
would be an example gel the student
would practice so it not only helps them
practice skill one but also the
transition between skill one and then
the common uh shape that often appears
with skill one across all expert
demonstrations
so to go over our approach we extract
skills from expert demonstrations we
then select scenarios with diverse
skills use that to get a good estimate
of individual student skill expertise
and then use this to automatically
create individualized drills
so our work has more detailed
experiments in synthetic models of
student learning but for this talk I'll
focus more on our human subject study
and we have two tasks in particular
parking a car and writing a sequence of
Balinese characters
honey belt interfaces for them where
students participate in the teaching
curriculum
so uh let's focus on the writing task
here the goal is to write Balinese
sequences of Balinese characters the
control mechanism is a continuous Mouse
control onto the interface and then the
expert we consider are real human
trajectories from the Omniglot data set
which is a crowdsource data set of human
handwriting trajectories
then the state space is a
two-dimensional State space of XY
positions and then the action space is
again two-dimensional of the x y
coordinate movement
for the parking task the goal here is to
park the yellow car into the blue square
um the control is again a continuous
Mouse control but this time operating a
joystick toggle and then the expert here
is an optimal RL agent soft after critic
agent that achieves 100 success rate in
parking
and then the state space is six
dimensional controlling the car's
position velocity and heading and then
the action space is the acceleration and
heading that the human can control
so the first experiment we want to study
is whether the skills returned from
compile does unsupervised skill
Discovery method whether it's actually
useful for human student learning
so one Baseline we can focus on is just
uh the student just practices full
trajectories so that's either practicing
a car parking the car in the blue square
the complete task of that or complete
sequences of Balinese characters and so
if this were to perform well this would
mean that we don't really need to think
about breaking down the task into skills
or drills we can just have the human
just practice the task over and over
again
we can also consider a Time heuristic
where the way we Define skills is we
break down a trajectory into even
segments based on the time so uh if it
takes 12 seconds then we could do three
segments of four seconds
um and if this were to perform well this
means we don't really need AI assistance
we can just have a very simple heuristic
to identify the skills we don't need
something fancy like compile
and then we have our method which is
based on compile skills and you can see
here that we're able to identify the
full uh turn as a skill for the car
versus just a straight segment
so we run a user study on the prolific
crowdsourcing platform and particularly
we measure reward Improvement which is
the difference between student
performance London evaluation set and
their pre-test set
and we can see that for both our tasks
using compile skills uh outperforms the
students learn more with compile-based
skills than to other Baseline methods
but in particular we can see that the
time heuristic is very inconsistent it
kind of does help with the writing task
but with the parking task students just
do not really learn that much at all
with the time heuristic which shows that
our method using compile skills not only
helps improve student learning but it's
more reliable and consistent across
different control tasks
and then finally our last experiment was
by their individualized drills now help
students learn
so we compare our focused skill based
practice
with randomly chosen drills so now we
have gels corresponding to targeting
different skills but this Baseline
doesn't have any individualized
component for each student they just
practice the randomly selected set of
skills
and then we have our method that's based
on individualization so we do our
process of identifying what skills a
student's struggling with and then
create drills that help them practice
this more
and what we can see here is the
distribution of what are the skills we
identified as being difficult for
different students and the corresponding
drills for them and so for example you
can see for the parking task the most
common skills students struggle with are
both reversing skills which kind of
makes sense based on the joystick being
hard to control with reversing actions
um but what you can also see here is
that there's a pretty widespread
distribution across individuals of what
are the challenging skills which shows
that individualization is pretty
important because it's not like there's
just one uniform skill that all students
needs all students need to improve on
and struggle with
and so in terms of results we see that
individualized drills does generally
improve student performance compared to
our baselines
and then we also have user self-report
the perceived helpfulness of the
teaching sessions and here we see
something interesting we see that
participants significantly prefer
individualized drills for the writing
task
but for the parking tasks participants
actually preferred the skill based
practice the shortest non-individualized
skill based practice over individualized
drills despite actually performing
better when they were taught with
individualized drills
so why is there this inconsistency
and we do a closer look at the expert
optimal expert actions in the evaluation
set and if you look at that you can see
that the optimal expert action for many
of those scenarios is to reverse
and then looking at the data we see that
students who didn't receive any
individualization doing teaching only 27
percent of them attempted to reverse in
those scenarios well more than half of
the students who did receive
individualization uh individualized
jills they tried to reverse but they
report in their feedback that they found
it pretty hard to control the toggle
when reversing and found it a hard skill
in general to do
so what this means here is that teaching
is not just teaching how to perform the
task with a high reward but also how to
kind of learn the skills that the expert
is using in particular and so what we
see is that students you know they are
learning how to perform the task better
because reversing does help them uh kind
of get a lower reward but they're
finding a more frustrating experience
because they're now having to learn a
much harder skill
so the key takeaways here is that um we
kind of developed this method for using
AI assistance for skill Discovery
individualization and Jill creation
three teaching components we identified
from motor control tasks
and the basic idea here was that it's a
lot easier to do a motor control task
than to teach it so we can have access
to a lot of expert demonstrations of
people performing a task but teaching is
something that's a lot harder a lot less
uniform currently that we can leverage
AI assistance for
and then finally we showed that
participants did benefit from AI
assistance for two pretty different
control tasks
um
in terms of future directions though I
want to focus on two one is having
stronger models of student motor
learning so we kind of showed these
crowdsourcing results but our overall
method has a lot of parameters there's a
degree of repetition in drills the
context length and drills compile itself
as a method and other unsupervised code
Discovery methods they have parameters
like the number of skills and the
overall tasks that you need to set
um and it would be nice to not have to
run a pretty costly uh human subject
study for each of these parameter
settings to be able to kind of identify
what would lead to a Better Learning
outcomes but right now we don't really
have good models of how students learn
particularly motor control tasks there's
been a lot more effort for more
simplified tasks
and we can have uh naive baselines like
have training or reinforcement learning
agent or having particularly like uh
semantic difficulties like uh having
this uh model have trouble with
reversing but these are pretty basic and
don't really kind of capture the way
students might learn a motor control
task such as incorporating things like
muscle fatigue muscle memory and
forgetting over time
and then another direction to consider
is the risks of our approach when
there's a mismatch between the expert
and the student and how to account for
student preferences so many motor
control tasks there might be many right
ways to do the task and if we only could
use data from one expert one way of
doing the task we might miss kind of
accounting for the different ways a
motor control tasks might be performed
so one user study here kind of had uh
they really like the overall tool but
they had a disability so they struggled
with the actual way of the attack the
task was being performed itself
so um kind of being able to estimate
student preferences really well and
figuring out what the right
demonstration from an expert are to
teach them is an important future
Direction
um and yeah that's it thank you
thank you
let's welcome our speakers back on stage
[Music]
um since we started about 10 minutes
late so we have until about 25 uh 12 25
oh
um we'll collect like the five questions
first
um I I will just keep going One
Direction
[Music]
um so um thank you both
um so my question is really uh just
um really it's a Casper's presentation
and I was wondering because as a lawyer
like we're very concerned with
explainability
um because we want reasons because
reasons are kind of the precondition of
normatively challenging and kind of what
is taken to be an assorted decision
otherwise so we want to know why
something's been decided
um but from your presentation it seems
and this is my kind of interpretation
that this is always going to be a kind
of self-referential problem for the
legal Observer right because it seems to
me that what you were saying is that
information only becomes meaningful and
you're using meaning in a really
interesting way
um if it's like a kind of a difference
that makes a difference to that Observer
there has to be a selection of a
meaningful like what is the relevant
difference and how that how that
information is presented so the medium
in which it's communicated actually
determines what possible understandings
can be drawn so just as I was listening
to I was really struck that this the way
you're presenting it was really resonant
with a kind of a series of second order
cybernetics and systems theory where one
has to sort of basically make a cut
between information and the medium in
order to generate understanding in the
meaning in the medium of meaning and I
say that's kind of a bit complicated but
my question is really just whether or
not you think that um the outputs of a
predictive system represented this way
can ever be translated with any sort of
certainty or whether we will always have
this kind of contingent relationship to
the position of the person that makes it
the distinction makes the observation of
the information and how it's presented
um yeah I don't know if that makes sense
you know but that's
sure
right I think that
everybody
okay yeah
all right um so my question is also for
Casper thank you so much for the
presentation to to both of you
um I like interpretability as you feel
because people tend to have like very
strong opinions other than other parts
of computer science so here's my with a
caveat like he's my own strong opinion I
think that intersubjective issues as the
ones that burnout where it was it was
hinting at
um might be a result of really focusing
on post-hoc methods too much right I
feel that um they will always kind of
fail because you're trying to extract
meaning from an idiosyncratically
compressed set of data
um I would even argue that postdoc
methods are almost an implicit
implicitly political choice right you're
treating models as if they were natural
objects that you have to study
empirically right you have to prod them
and to analyze them
um so the less strong version of that is
why are we not focusing on naturally
explainable models what's keeping us
technically or otherwise
um you know from going up like jumping
before the point where we have to kind
of like empirically analyze these
systems if that makes sense
do you think then like the computer
vision algorithms or NLP algorithms that
are not inherently explainable shouldn't
have been invented in the first place
that like I guess I'm trying to draw a
boundary I know it's like a fuzzy sort
of spectrum but you cannot do it right
um but then there's maybe there's a
middle ground yeah so there's maybe
deeper ways
basically that you know goes a little
bit deeper it tends to be but then again
the regulations that you get from that
um are you know Up For Debate and uh not
really interpretable so it's a question
so yeah yeah that's helpful I'll leave
it to the speakers
um I have a question for Casper and then
for both of those speakers
um so for Casper I was wondering do you
have an example of an explainability
method that's been like used and shown
to be helpful for the intended audience
and if not what are the like biggest
challenges to getting there
um and then for both of you I guess both
of you are working at least in the
papers you've uh presented on things
where the end user is a human like
ultimately you're outputting something
that needs to be useful to a human and
I'm wondering in a lot of like in both
interpretability and and HRI and I know
Casper you said you think maybe we've
gone too much focused on the human
um the way that these methods are
evaluated with people are typically in
like very small user studies often
recruited by the persons like in the
person's own lab like to what extent do
you think like this is okay versus we
need better evaluations versus I don't
know it's outside of the domain yeah
what do you think about rigorous
evaluation
[Music]
Applause
okay yeah we'll finish here movement
okay
well I have a question for for Mega the
second speaker so maybe we can just I'm
happy to wait and then
thank you very much
right could you define it helpful
yeah so who is the end user if the end
user is a machine learning engineer then
helpless oh can I get some insights into
why my model breaks or what's wrong with
it so that's one definition of helpful
in this context
and then another definition of helpful
is oh I've seen the explanation so now I
feel more confident
about these model making decisions
regardless of whether the explanation is
correct or
what the explanation does so I suppose
we've gone overboard into we want to
understand that we we just want to
generate an explanation but and then
this ties back to your question about
uh what was oh the evaluation
I don't think it's possible to evaluate
the method in such a way that then we
can draw broader conclusions so however
we evaluate it it's in a given context
with a given people and that's why I
draw this clear separation between
generating insights and presenting the
insights so for example with uh let's
say counterfactual so what if questions
you know that this if you've generated
and then you can probe the model is this
what if instance correct it is correct
right so then it's just a matter of how
you present it
and that probably depends on who you
present to
Etc so you know there is a correct or
possibly objectively correct inside and
then how you present it to whom and for
what purpose
hopefully that I guess I don't mean like
for a particular model like you're
trying to make the explanation for a
model generalized well I mean
it's from the field of exploitability
generalizable can be evaluate like that
I suppose we should completely forget
about where the explanation comes I
think we have the other questions okay
so then the other question was context
right so you said that possibly we may
be better off just by using transparent
methods
and again it's context dependent if you
want to deploy this model it affects
humans and yes of course because all the
postdoc methods can do is give you one
single Peak inside what's happening so
then if we're deploying it in a mission
critical situation it should definitely
be transparent whereas if you're an
engineer or you're you're just curious
then why not use postpon it also gives
you some sort of insight as long as you
understand
the conditions
under which it was generated this
insight and how to interpret it so it
just plays a completely different role
and one shouldn't be used in certain
situations whereas another can be used
I'm not saying that one is better than
the other they just serve a different
purpose
and Bernard I
I'm sorry
okay
okay
I'm the hungry one so I don't
um this is a question for Mega and it's
a little like uh tangential
it's a it's a question about the
politics of what you're doing and it
makes me so worried when computer
science digital technology whatever
enters into the sphere of Education
and your motivation for what the project
is is very benign you know they're
people who don't have access to these
motor skill uh teachings and so we're
being helpful but there is always this
dimension of
um the descaling dimension of saying we
don't need the teachers anymore we're
going to
um create methods uh where we can
um automate this process I'm now seeing
the world through Peter's eyes which is
number one be Skilling number two
and your tasks by the way also the one
for me non-problematic because we're
talking about parking and and writing
Balinese characters but if if you have
aspirations to extend it to more complex
teaching tasks I think that becomes
dangerous because
um you can simplify
and as we've talked about I'm not sure
how much you've been with us but um a
lot of these tasks must be reduced in
order to be made computationally
accessible and so then the task becomes
whatever is computation the teaching
becomes what is computationally
accessible you know education is it
Reading Writing arithmetic or is it a
much bigger transfer of human knowledge
to the Next Generation and maybe it just
becomes the thing that we can do with an
automated system
so
um it's hard for people like myself who
are not technologists but I feel like
folks like yourselves who are working on
this like we need to know you're
thinking about this and I'm wondering if
you are
[Music]
thank you
um so
first of all great talks both of you my
question is for Mega um uh I one thing
that I notice about the task itself or
both of the tasks that you're testing on
is that they're stable and and
um they're specific tasks but it strikes
me that a big goal of motor skill
development and of like drills as a
strategy is to develop skills that are
kind of adaptable
so that when the world changes or when
there are random conditions in an
evaluation
um
somebody might be able to adapt to those
changes so I guess I just want to hear
like your thoughts about that or how
that could get incorporated into your
work or or as a general topic of inquiry
I'll start with your question first
because I think I will look a lot worse
with yours but um uh with uh yeah I
think teaching I think like in a way
that helps humans adapt to new tasks is
definitely important we try to get that
a bit with like having these different
scenarios and conditions with parking
like
um just like uh different kind of
starting points whether the orientation
is towards or against a parking spot and
then kind of the skills we kind of
identify do need to be able to transfer
across these different scenarios but I
think it's an interesting thing to think
about like skills that are adaptable
across very different motor control
tasks because you do have this idea of
like you know there is something similar
to where it's breaking in a bike and
breaking in a car but they are also
different but you kind of like there is
some transfer that's happening
so I guess I'll have to really say for
that is like that is like something I'm
pretty interested in looking into more
um but I I think especially with what I
talk about with like human AI
coordination tasks like taking over a
self-driving car or assistive uh surgery
tele operation I think um those are
pretty new tasks that we just like don't
even have teachers kind of for yet and
those are kind of examples where we're
kind of just expecting humans to be able
to adapt to them
um and just like as we kind of introduce
new and new technology we're just
expecting counting on humans ability to
adapt so I think being able to help like
teach humans to adapt better towards new
kind of motor control tests that's also
I think an important thing and I think
that ties into my uh response to your
question which is um this is something
I've been grappling with a lot
um because I also feel like education is
so much more than just like teaching a
task that's also being in a classroom
with other students and kind of seeing
your peers learn is kind of having kind
of the inspiration from a human teacher
and their kind of mentorship so I think
I never really kind of see this work as
uh replacing that part of teaching but I
do think and I think like from both my
work on with like language learning and
this work
um
I think just the reality is and you know
like
um like I meet many people who kind of
do Embrace a lot of these technology
like uh education technology because
they just don't have access aren't able
to afford certain kind of specialized
teaching and I think I've grappled with
this a lot because I also
I'm hesitant to just like automating
away teaching I don't think like we
could ever really fully replace all the
teachers offer but I also do think like
I come every point where I've had like
pretty privileged access to kind of
education both in extracurricular
activities and in school and I've never
really faced a situation where I've like
needed to resort to kind of getting
resources for otusa for my education
um like uh and kind of just like finding
them and I do think there's an
opportunity to just think about how we
could like increase that kind of access
and then kind of related to the two
points like I do think we're just
entering this world where we're
introducing a lot of kind of control
tasks without even like thinking how to
teach them and so we don't even have
like teachers teaching these kinds of
tests but we're just kind of like having
humans just learn through trial and
error how to perform them and I think
that's where I see kind of uh My Method
being particularly useful which is what
are these kind of control tasks where we
just haven't even put in the resources
to learn how to have humans teach them
but can we kind of get something kind of
in the middle ground as we kind of learn
how to get good human teachers for them
that's still kind of like helps us learn
how to do it in the process
I'm going to pay you all this money so
that we become the Distributors of your
method like how
right now if we don't have the local
teacher teaching a kid which costs a
certain amount of money but we have I
think about the reality of the political
economy and how these automated systems
can be centralized the controllables can
also decentralized and also limited
through economics
but so when you say we that's that's not
all maybe maybe you will but
I think this is a concern I'm sorry
I realized that
this is also kind of picking up on the
discussion here I think um I understand
Megan where you're coming from entirely
but I wonder whether one of the things
that Helen's concerned about and maybe
others is that when we disaggregate
skills whether they're motor skills or
communicative skills from sensitivities
and sensibilities
then we run the risk of really
impoverishing people in terms of
learning outcomes versus learning
opportunities
when you develop sensitivities and
sensibilities then you're opening up
relational opportunities for taking that
learning to the next level the next
level it's like I'm a surfer I know what
it would be like when people get trained
to go surfing and they come out and line
up and they have no idea what the
sensitivities they're dealing with other
Surfers are
there's a pecking order there's a
priorities and there's a there's a
culture of it going on and if they come
out there without that they get hurt or
they get other people really upset and
then they get hurt on the beach
so it's kind of like if you're not
giving them the full spectrum background
into what's involved in that learning
test let's say it's Balinese writing
and they're not in fact informed that
writing is a sacred Act
that it's a religious sort of communion
with those processes that humans have
been embroiled with for centuries
millennia
then the test just becomes a movement a
motor skill and so it's like I know that
a lot of these systems are being say
used for working with autistic children
developing them to be able to skip have
the skills to engage
with people so they seem neural normal
but when in fact they're not developing
the sensitivities and sense the
sensibility so I think that's a way of
neuronsing and then maybe you just put
your research in a bigger context
because that's they don't do what you're
doing but I think what Helen's saying is
we need to really put it in the bigger
societal context yeah
[Music]
yeah I think I definitely agree and I
think the like uh example of writing is
a pretty good one and I think we did get
feedback from a couple people like
saying they really wish they like knew
what the characters meant and that's
something to be like oh we didn't do but
like we could have done and I think
there's just kind of like even kind of
the students desire some kind of
information like this what is the what
is Balinese like uh use the script use
for what what are like interesting words
that they want to learn and all and then
also yeah like from the perspective of
people who write Balinese kind of giving
those like awareness of the task I think
maybe it's a matter of perspective
whether I view it as kind of improving
these methods versus not doing something
like this at all because it currently
doesn't adjust the sensitivities
I have a question to you so somewhat
related to our discussion here I think
like for surfing like take surfing as an
example I think the fact that people
would just come out of surfing school go
into the beach to look a bit out of
place and have still have a lot of
skills left to learn that seems fine to
me that doesn't say the surfing school
is not useful so in a sense I think I
think that's aligns with your point
which is like the skills AI teaches is
sort of part of this larger picture
larger skill set you need to learn and
sort of related to that
um in your talk you have this diagram
about heart problems versus simpler
problems problems that worse your system
to solve versus not I found that
categorization really interesting can
you maybe say a bit more about your
um what like did in your studies do you
notice anything about how AI categorize
or how from a technical perspectives
what are hard versus simple problems and
how that how much of that aligns with
people's perception or of our common
Assumption of what's difficult versus
Daisy that's how you mean like the
charts showing what were the skills
found challenging for students versus
not
um like those curved Parts yeah and I
think the slide before you were talking
about here are some problems that you
really don't need can can can be solved
by simple heuristic systems versus here
it is problems
like worse com uh your system to solve
yeah I guess
um so what that thought was showing was
kind of what our system identifies as
students struggling with and then
I think the heuristic the idea there was
like it's like a non-ai assisted way of
kind of breaking down the task into
skills
um
sorry to clarify is your question like
whether kind of the skills students
struggle with kind of
match up like an AI agent would struggle
with or
um like match what we'd expect students
to struggle with the letter that's the
question
um I mean I can only speak for myself
personally like I yeah I also find
reversing cards I think it's like not
surprising that that was like found as a
hard skill
um I think in terms of the writing tasks
I was a bit surprised because I found
that those seemed like pretty simple so
I think uh like
um but I can really only speak it's hard
to really even know like
writing Balinese that's not like a
common like task that people in
education study even like I I I don't
have that knowledge of uh What uh would
be a hard skill and I think that's kind
of one point I was trying to make with
the distinction between this work and
approaches in education for like math
and foreign language we just don't have
like the Decades of Education research
on motor control tasks on what are hard
skills that are task specific so it's
hard to really say without kind of
honing in on a particular task and
hoping there are enough kind of experts
out there who have done scholarship on
that particular task on what would be
the expected difficult skills in the
same way we have for links something
like language learning
great thank you
um any more questions
okay if not we'll wrap it up thanks
everyone and I think there are a lot of
discussions to have I think the
explanability research really aligns
well with auditing like algorithms
auditing over a lot of law [ __ ]
um professionals here so maybe we can
continue the conversation
over lunch and any other contexts but
thanks everyone really wonderful
discussion
[Applause]
all right